>> OH, MY GOD.
DID YOU GUYS HEAR THERE'S A NEW
VARIANT?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> OH, MY GOD, ANOTHER ONE?
>> DUDE?
>> WHEN IS COVID GONNA BE OVER?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> OH, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
APPARENTLY THIS ONE IS GOOD.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN, "IT'S
GOOD"?
>> I DUNNO, LET ME JUST --
>> -- HAPPENING.
FOR TODAY, THEY'RE CALLING IT A
MIRACLE.
A NEW STRAIN OF COVID-19 THAT'S
MUTATED SO HARD, IT'S ACTUALLY
GOOD.
>> WAIT.
NO.
>> IT'S CALLED THE GELVENIE
VARIANT, AND IT DOESN'T MAKE YOU
SICK, IT JUST MAKES YOU FEEL
DOPE.
>> OH, MY --
>> WHAT?
>> WAIT, WAIT.
DUDE, IT LIKE DOESN'T GIVE YOU A
FEVER OR ANYTHING?
>> NO, IT JUST MAKES YOU FEEL,
LIKE, COOL AND CONFIDENT.
>> IT COMES FROM THE SANDY
BEACHES OF CABO SAN LUCAS.
>> DUDE, HAVING GELVENIE IS LIKE
HAVING A DRINK WITH AN OLD
FRIEND.
>> BEER ME.
>> OH, MY GOD.
FAUCI'S TELLING PEOPLE TO GO TO
THE CLUBS.
>> OH!
>> WE HAVE TO GO.
[ KNOCKING ]
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> HEY.
>> I, UM, TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE GELVENIE VARIANT, AND IT
ACTUALLY MADE ME SICK.
>> OH, SHOOT.
>> AT PLAYIN' SYNTH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
♪♪
>> WE ARE POSITIVE!
YOU'RE POSITIVE.
>> YOU'RE POSITIVE!
YOU'RE POSITIVE!
>> THIS JUST IN, I'M GOING ON
VACAY!
SEE YOU IN BALI, BITCHES!
>> YEAH!
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHO'S HUNGRY?
>> DID SOMEBODY SAY HUNGRY?
>> CHUG, CHUG, CHUG, CHUG.
♪♪
>> YO, YO, YO, FAUCI JUST PUT
OUT A STATEMENT!
>> WHAT'D HE SAY?
>> HE JUST HOOKED UP WITH
SWEENEY.
>> GO FAUCI!
GO FAUCI!
GO SWEENEY!
>> MARTIN, YOU'RE POSITIVE.!
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> NO, FOR ANAL WORMS.
>> WHAT?
>> BUT WE CAUGHT IT EARLY!
>> YEAH, COME THROUGH.
>> AND HOLDIN' UP, A NEW
SYMPTOM.
APPARENTLY THE GOOD VARIANT
GIVES YOU LONG, LUSCIOUS LOCKS.
>> OH, BOY.
>> AND GUESS WHAT ELSE, Y'ALL?
>> WHAT UP, DUDE MAN?
>> POKEMON ARE REAL!
LOOK AT THIS --
>> WE'RE GONNA LIVE FOREVER!
>> DID SOMEONE SAY HUNGRY?
>> I DID A WHILE AGO.
BUT YEAH, COME ON IN, MAN.
>> MILKMAN!
>> GO PAUL!
GO PAUL!
>> COVID'S OVER AND EVERYTHING'S
GONNA ROCK FOREVER.
[ CHEERS ]
>> OH, MAN.
>> THIS JUST IN.
POKEMON HAVE STORMED THE
CAPITOL.
I REPEAT.
POKEMON HAVE STORMED THE
CAPITOL.
>> OH, GOD.
>> OH, WAIT.
OH, HOLD UP, Y'ALL.
THEY'RE JUST THERE TO PASS
AWESOME LEGISLATION!